all right so recordings going everyone
good morning it's
great to have you all with us again
thanks for joining us
we're looking at areas by integration
this morning and the way i want to begin
um being that this is an area we've had
a look at in the past but we're going to
go into further depth
today what i want to do is call your
mind back to a previous lesson when we
were looking at
the fundamental theorem of calculus what
we're trying to get across to you like
my big mission
during that lesson was to help you
understand that this process of
differentiation which we know about
and its reverse which we first introduce
is anti-differentiation then we get a
new name
integration it gives you area but it
doesn't do it
by magic it does it because of the way
that a function a primitive
is related to its derivative and there's
something really key
and visual at the base at the foundation
of
calculus which which leads to this
result right so
i want you to remember that the
integration is something we connected
very closely to area
and it kind of felt like this right if
you want to start your notes
for today um the derivative right
what did it give you it was going to
give you a rate of change
and what that looked like geometrically
that's a really messy word but i think
you get what i'm talking about
a rate of change geometrically is a
gradient you know the steeper it is
the faster that it's changing the
shallower it is the slower it's changing
if there's a gradient of zero if it's
flat it's not changing at all
and of course if your gradient is
negative that means your rate of change
is also negative so whatever it is that
you had
is getting lower and lower smaller and
smaller and all the rest
now an integral by contrast is not about
a rate of change
i wonder if anyone remembers i'm i'm
sort of
giving away the fact because i have my
old notes from the last lesson there
a rate of change is the derivative but
the total change
is the integral right now what does that
look like visually this was us trying to
connect it
to area now this idea that integration
and area thank you hamza
are connected is the real key but what
i'm
now going to try and push on this lesson
is the fact that these two things
integral and area whilst being connected
are not exactly the same there is
there's some subtle distinctions
to be made between them so in order to
try and tease out
what those things are we're going to do
a series of area
questions that will require us to use
integration to really
nut out what the what the values are
what the answers are
but as we go through them i want to make
sure that we have a logical sort of
setup for how to actually do all these
questions
so i've got kind of like a three-step
guide for you here okay
um i'm pretty bad at making up acronyms
but
this one i think hopefully will stick in
your brain for area questions
there's always three steps yeah i i
thought you might appreciate that jason
i wasn't going to say it myself but now
that you said i feel like gives me
permission
for area questions you want it to be
sick okay step one
s step two i step three c
s stands for sketch two stands or i
rather stands for
identify your integrals and c
then stands for combining those
integrals and bringing together
a conclusion so sketch identify your
integrals
then combine and conclude and it's worth
noting this three-step
sort of guide here if you like it it
generally applies to every area question
that you're going to encounter but
sometimes depending on the question
you won't have to for example do the
sketch they might provide you a drawing
from the outset or depending on the kind
of area that you have to evaluate there
might not be any
combining you and you need to do you
just have to conclude you'll see it all
make sense once i give you some concrete
examples so for area questions we wanted
to be sick we're going to sketch
identify
and combine and conclude so let's have a
look at this first example to see how it
all fits together
the question says find the area of the
region bounded by y equals
3x minus x squared and the x
axis so no picture has been provided so
the first step in
our i'm going to write it up on the top
corner here s
i c our first step is we're going to
sketch this thing now
the the question is not to draw so you
don't have to worry about making this
you know beautiful and precise but you
still do have to have it
accurate enough that you can draw some
conclusions from it
so having a look at this function up
here maybe you don't have an immediate
image in your mind
of what this thing looks like but you
can help hopefully tell me in the
comments
what's the general shape of what we're
going to get here help me out what kind
of
graph am i going to draw roughly
speaking
yes thumbs up well done uh
fantastic everyone's identifying the
correct shape so we're going to get a
parabola here
and then the question is well what kind
of parabola now yes very good yvonne
it's upside down the way you can tell
it's upside down
is the coefficient of x squared which is
the part that is important it's negative
let's try and get a little more detail
on this right i'm going to factorize
this that will make it easier to
identify the features
so the common factor is an x
and then what that leaves me with in the
brackets is a
three takeaway x right so i'm factorized
i'm done
what does that tell us well
factorization once you've got your two
factors
they tell you well what do they tell you
the factors what kind of information can
i get
from the factors and you want to go
ahead and write it in the chat
what kind of information am i looking
for from each individual factor
yes the intercept is perfect x
intercepts even better abby that's great
detail so
let me go in further detail on that from
the x
factor see what i did there um you're
going to get an x-intercept of x equals
zero
and you're going to get a nice chiming
in there sorry well done
what what they said um from the three
minus x
factor you're going to get x equals
three
as your x-intercept okay yeah so
i'm going to start to put all of this on
a very very rough um
set of axes and again it doesn't have to
be beautiful you don't need a hundred
percent of the information that you
would normally
have to provide if the questions said
hey graph this
you'll see the parts that are relevant
for us so here's my
very rough and messy coordinate set of
axes here
i know i'm gonna have an x-intercept to
zero
i'm gonna have an x-intercept at three
and then as i think as yvonne said right
up the top we're gonna have this
negative
uh facing down concave down parabola
okay so this is the shape that we've got
this is y equals 3x minus
x squared now even though it's not
beautiful or intricate and i'm missing
lots of other information like where's
that vertex and that kind of thing
i actually have all the information i
need go back to the question and say
it says find the area of the region
bounded by that curve the blue one
and the x-axis so there's kind of like
this fenced-in area that we're looking
at there
and hopefully you can see it right there
in the middle this is the one we're
after in here
which i'm shading in green okay so if
this
is the area that i'm now trying to
evaluate i've done step one
s for sketch now i need to identify the
integral that tells me
the size of that area i'm getting the
area under a curve so i'm going to say
area i'll leave it as blue that's fine
is an integral and because i'm looking
for an area i need a definite integral
here
right so i need some boundaries i need a
lower boundary where do i start
and i need an upper boundary where i end
you want to jump in on the comments and
tell me what my boundaries should be
lower and then upper ah well done sasha
even with lag that's like instant
fantastic work now parent is right it is
three and zero but be careful
um if you think all the way back mrs lee
taught us a lesson on the properties of
a definite integral
so even though apparently i'm sure you
didn't mean for one to be one and one
the other um the order does matter
in our in our um boundaries that
integral here if i integrate it from
three to zero
you get exactly the negative of going
from zero to three so let mariam says
we'll go go lower is zero and the higher
one is three
we usually say upper okay so there's my
boundaries
the thing that i'm integrating is three
x take away x
squared and then i go with respect to x
so this is the integral
that i need let me move this guy a
little over here so i have some more
space to work
okay now at this point here you might
say okay i'm i know how to do this i'm
pretty good with it right um
integrals increase indices so this is
going to become in our square brackets
here
3x squared and then we divide by our new
power
and then we subtract and then i'm going
to increase indices one more time
x cubed on three close bracket there's
my provided function
i'm integrating from naught to three
so i've got uh something now to put
values into i'm just going to do the
straight substitution without any
simplification
so i get 3 times 3 squared
on 2 take away 3 cubed
on 3. does that look like i got my upper
bound
okay and then i'm going to subtract and
this becomes 0 take away 0.
okay it's a bit of a messy bracket there
all right
so have a look um thumbs up did you get
that was that looking all right to you
let me get some confirmation that you
guys just substituted correctly that
i've substituted correctly
thank you mary sasha much appreciated
okay now i've done my straight
substitution
perfect lawrence let's actually start to
simplify this thing so 3 times 3 squared
is 27
over 2 and then i've got 27 over
3 take away 0.
i've got a factor i guess of 27 out
there a half
take away a third and i happen to know
if you
check your common denominators there a
half take away a third is a sixth
because it's three-sixths
take away two-sixths six is really hard
to say
um so i've got 27 divided by six and i
can simplify that one more time
because it's a common factor of three on
the top and bottom so that gives me
9 over 2 or 4 and a half
okay now what have i done so far well i
sketched that's what you can see over
here on the right hand side
i identified my integral and then i went
ahead and calculated what my integral
was
now i'm ready to do the last step which
is to combine and then conclude
now in this case there's not much to
combine you'll see later on sometimes we
will get
more than one integral that we need to
put together in some careful way
in this case there was just the one
integral so i'm going to skip the
combined bit
but i'm going to conclude and i'm going
to encourage you it's slightly nitpicky
and pedantic but
rather than just saying oh this is an
area
i'm just going to put units squared on
the end right
i generally try and avoid that as much
as possible like can you get away with
it
probably but the technically accurate
way is that that integral you started
with had no units
attached to it and depending on what
this question was you know if we think
back to
over here you know this integral here
it's not about
uh you know units squared it's about
cases per day
right it will be a number of cases so
your units actually
should be careful with so rather than
just doing an integral and then saying
oops it's an area so therefore i should
um
put unit squared on the end a conclusion
is better i would say
therefore the area
is this is 9 over 2. so 9
over 2 units squared full stop
so like i said that's kind of the most
technically accurate way to say it you
probably could just get away with it by
tacking unit squared on the end but i'm
trying to set you a good example here
so this is the best way to do it we
sketched we identified the integral
and then we combined and concluded all
right